[Musique]
alors soutenez-vous le restaurateur
sous quel le restaurateur oui non choqué
pas choqué c'est pas là qui soutient le
restaurateur dit oui
effectivement je trouve que c'est pas
très élégant et tout ça mais après tout
peut-être que parfois quand on est dans
un restaurant on n'a pas envie d'avoir
une poussette avec un mot qui pleure à
côté et métier d'accueillir des gens non
tu as des enfants
les enfants des autres que je ne vais
pas puis que j'en ai eu j'ai dit bah si
c'est normal c'est des enfants non mais
c'est pas j'ai pas de dire si c'est
normal ou pas normal d'abord il est chez
lui il fait ce qu'il veut et s'il a
envie d'avoir
fait pour sa gueule parce que justement
les gens seront contents d'aller dans un
endroit extrêmement calme sans enfant
qui crie ou qui braille je suis en train
de regarder des papiers
et les restaurants c'est pas des
baby-sitter aussi pour les enfants les
poussettes et voilà il y a des enfants
pour ça et des enfants des restaurants
qu'il est 22h que tu vois un gamin dans
un endroit
que pour 10h
12h30 13h30
dans un landau effectivement tu te dis
d'abord c'est pas sa place
à 3h du matin qui est en train de boire
du whisky et de défoncer tous les sapins
de Noël
c'est que la plupart des temps
effectivement les gens qui ont des
enfants bah pardon les garde pas ils
courent partout ils font du bruit quand
tu es au resto et que tu vas dans un
resto tu vas maman de détente avec
quelqu'un tu as pas envie d'avoir un
gamin qui hurle la merde
là encore c'est une histoire
moi que mes enfants mais jumeaux ils ont
10 ans qui se mettent à parler un peu
fort que Jules il a envie de chanter une
chanson je dis non non tu peux pas faire
ça donc c'est les parents arrivent les
enfants
ni par leur bruit ni par quoi que ce
soit
mon fils
il est génial
il voulait chanter dans le restaurant
voilà il [ __ ] la merde tout ça voilà
il a repris le droit chemin quoi
les enfants font mieux ça suffit
direct c'est une autorité là c'est
extrêmement choquant et pour et vous
êtes qui vous je ne vous connais pas
monsieur pour répondre à Géraldine il
n'est pas chez lui c'est un lieu qui
accueille du public
des enfants sont potentiellement mal
élevés ça c'est de la responsabilité
ça a fait un scandale le syndicat
d'initiative est contre lui il est tout
seul il ne sait plus comment se dépêtrer
de ça et franchement ce qu'il a fait
c'est honteux j'adore les restaurateurs
mais lui ne mérite pas d'accueillir du
public voilà celui de faire faillite
aussi j'ai dit qu'il devrait retirer ses
affiches et c'est assumer les choses
qui prouvent qu'il est pas temps dans la
merde que ça comme ça
apparemment il y a pas mal de gens qui
sont
je trouve ça honteux je trouve ça
inhumain je pense que ces personnes ont
peut-être oublié que eux aussi ça a été
des enfants un jour qu'ils ont déjà
pleuré qu'ils ont déjà crié
de la vie il faut être un peu indulgent
un peu humain désolé une pancarte pas
d'enfant devant un resto pour moi c'est
de la vieux pire c'est les enfants dans
la vie de la discrimination
23C tu as un enfant en 24 heures
excusez-moi c'est insupportable si vous
dites en tête-à-tête avec votre amoureux
et vous avez un enfant
est dans l'avion c'est source
d'embrouille à chaque fois
Valérie tu vas à la table à côté
gentiment tu leur dis oui 30 ans fait du
bruit tu vas voir ce qui va se passer
comment les parents vont recevoir sinon
tu sors du restaurant
dans le restaurant Mathieu c'est tout
c'était pas content les enfants ils
vivent ils s'exprime et puis
construisent leur futur et toi tu as des
enfants mais tu as des enfants de 45 ans
tu me fais chier non mais sans déconner
ils sont toujours en 4e